اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
هجوم غير مسبوق بالدبابات على الاراضي
الروسيه وظهور جديد لمعارضين مسلحين
لبوتين على الحدود
بيانهم سعودي امريكي تعليق مفاوضات الهدنه
في السودان لعدم جديه طرفي الصراع والحث
على حمايه المدنيين
بالمناطق الشماليه
ولدينا ايضا
يستعد مع ثلاثه مرشحين لمنافسه ترامب على
سباق الجمهوريين للبيت الابيض
بدايه العربيه 360 هذه ليله من الهجوم غير
المسبوق الذي تعرضت له مقاطعه
اذ اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط
محاوله اقتحام اوكرانيا للاراضي الروسيه
واكدت في بيان مشاركه نحو 70 مسلحا اضافه
الى خمس دبابات واربع مدرعات وسبع شاحنات
في الهجوم
تم الحديث عن القضاء على نحو خمسين مسلحا
اوكرانيا في المناطق الحدوديه
من جانبه اكد الناطق باسم الكرملين
لا يمكن ان تؤثر في مسار العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه كما شاركو لاعب
السلطات الاقليميه تتعامل مع الضربات
بنشاط كبير وبتفان دانا صمت الغرب جراء
الهجمات الاوكرانيه على الحدود الروسيه
من جديد تزامن الهجوم البري على مقاطعه
الروسيه الحدوديه مع ظهور جديد لعناصر ما
يسمى بفيلق روسيا الحره وفيلق المتطوعين
الروس الذين توعدوا بمواصله الهجمات في
العمق الروسيه
اطلقهما مسلحون روس ينتمون لما يسمى بفيلق
روسيا الحره وفيلق المتطوعين الروس
الجماعتان الروسيتان المدعومتان من كييف
كثافه من ظهورهما مؤخرا وبعد كل هجوم
يستهدف روسيا المشاهد الجديده تاتي بعد
يومين من استهداف موسكو دون ان يعرف زمان
ومكان تسجيلها
المجموعتان تقولان انهما ستنفدان هجمات
جديده داخل الاراضي الروسيه
هدفهما وفقا لتصريحات افرادها هو تحرير
روسيا من حكم بوتين يقول مسلح فيلق روسيا
الحره انهم لن يتوقفوا حتى ترفع رايتهم في
سماء العاصمه موسكو في المشاهد الجديده
يؤكد المسلحون انهم لن يستهدفوا المدنيين
ابقوا في منازلكم ولا تقلقوا مقاتله
الفيلق الروسي لا يقاتلون ضد المدنيين
[موسيقى]
للحديث عن اخر التطورات الميدانيه في
بيلجورو ينضموا الينا من هناك مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشود على ان نعرض
تقريرك بعد قليل عن زيارتك لاحد مراكز
اللاجئين في مركز المدينه عبد الجواد ولكن
كيف هو الوضع الان
مساء الخير يا طاهر حتى هذه اللحظه طاهر
ما زالت اعداد النازحين تصل الى المدينه
من شيبكينا يعني هذه الاعداد يزيد عددها
في مركزين فقط عن 1500 شخص تتوجه سلطات
الاقليم لنقل القسم الاكبر منهم من
المناطق الحدوديه وكانوا قد سمحوا لهم
باستقلال سياراتهم للوصول الى هنا الى
مركز بيلجراند التحذيرات الطاهر يعني في
اخر التحضير التحديثات ما زالت تصل تصل
لسكان بعض تلك المناطق حول الضربات التي
تدور على مدار الساعه نلاحظ على تيليجرام
وهو طبعا البرنامج النشيط الان بما يخص
نقل الاخبار في بيليج بان الضربات ومقاطع
الفيديو التي تظهر هذا الشيء تتوالى يعني
كل دقيقه حول هذا الموضوع في اخر
الاحصائيات طاهر خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه خرج منذ قليل الحاكم بيلغراد
وتحدث عن ان شيبكينا وهي النقطه الساخنه
الاكبر التي تلقت خلال الليله الماضيه
وخمسه عشره ضربه الجانب الاوكراني حسب
روايه السلطات الخسائر هي هناك خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه وصلت الى ثلاثه
ابنيه عاليه 14 منزلا خاصا اربع سيارات
كانت متوقفه ثلاث مباني حكوميه منشاه
صناعيه العديد من المحالات التجاريه ضرب
لشبكات الكهرباء وتعطل شبكه الاتصال
والغاز في بعض المناطق حتى ان حكومه
المدينه للسيطره على هذا الوضع قامت
بانشاء حواجز طاهر امام مداخل منعا للسكان
من العوده الى تلك المناطق الوجوه طبعا
وقراءه ما يحدث هناك طائر ستتابعه بشكل
يعني واضح وسيظهر في التقرير لكن يمكنني
القول يعني ما رواه سكان تلك المناطق هو
ما تتحدث عنه حكومه الاقليم بان الوضع في
الاقليم في بيل جراند يتجه نحو الاسوا
حمسنا نشوف التقرير لنذهب اليه مباشره عبد
الجواد الرسل مراسل العربيه من شكرا جزيلا
لك بالجراد حيث تستمر عمليه نزوح
المواطنين الروس من المناطق والقرى
الحدوديه في المقاطعه نحو مناطق اكثر امنا
بسبب القصف الذي تتعرض له المدينه ووصلت
الاعداد
وتحديدا
وقد وصلت الاعداد الى 4000 شخص في عده
مراكز تتوزع في مدينه بلغرود
ايام ساخنه تعيشها مدينه شيبكينا تعد
الاعنف خلال فتره الصراع ما دفع سلطات
الاقليم لانشاء مراكز مؤقته لاواء سكان
المناطق الحدوديه داخل مدينه بلغراد
عمليه القصف كانت باسلحه مخيفه تركنا كل
شيء واخذنا ما استطعنا حمله سريعا والده
اضطرت لترك القطه والكلب والنباتات وهربت
نحن ايضا رحلنا هذا المكان هو سلطه رياضيه
للكره الطائره تم تعديلها واعاده تنسيقها
سريعا لاستقبال اللاجئين
الناس هنا اصبحوا يدركون ما حدث بسبب
وضعهم النفسي وبدات تظهر اعراض الوضع من
ارتفاع للضغط او تغير في مستويات السكر
الكثير من الناس تم اجلائهم سريعا لذلك لم
يتمكنوا من جمع اشيائهم ولذلك نحن نقوم
بمساعدتهم الارقام هنا تتجاوز حاجز الالف
ومن المقرر استيعاب 250 اخرين عودتهم الى
منازلهم رهن باستقرار الوضع في المنطقه
لكن وحسب روايه السلطات الوضع في الاقليم
يزداد سوءا عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
قال رئيس الفرنسي مانيوال ماكرون ان بلاده
مستمره في دعم اوكرانيا من اجل تقويم
هجومها المضاده روسيا مكروه اضافها ان
بلاده تعمل على التنسيق مع الشركاء من دول
التحالف لتتمكن من الحصول على ضمانات
امنيه من النيتو لكنه لم يستبعد ايضا
التواصل مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ورغم دعم الغربي قالت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لانا انه لا يمكن لحلف
الناتو قبول عضويه الدوله تخوض حربا اكدت
ايضا ان سياسه الباب المفتوح التي تتبعها
او يتبعها الناتو لا تزال ساريه ولكن لا
يمكن لدوله الانضمام الى التحالف بينما
تخوض حربا
منذ
نتيجه الحرب العدوانيه الروسيه التعاون مع
اوكرانيا والنيتو زاد بشكل مكثف لذلك
النيتو كان واضحا بشان سياسه ابوابه
المفتوحه للانضمام اليه لكن بنفس الوقت لا
يمكن مناقشه عضويه جديده لدوله تاخد حربا
اجتمع اليوم في كيب تاون بجنوب افريقيا
وزراء خارجيه دول البريكس تحضيرا لقمه
رؤساء هذه الدول في اغسطس المقبل وفي حين
لم يتم الاعلان عن جدول اعمال الاجتماع
لكن محللين قالوا ان المناقشات تهدف الى
النظر في توسيع المجموعه وتعميق العلاقات
بين الاعضاء الحاليين وهم البرازيل روسيا
الهند الصين وجنوب افريقيا
اجتماع اليوم هيمنه عليه الجدل لاحتمال
حضور الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
المستهدف بامر اعتقال من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه مجموعه البريكس تاسست بحسب محللين
لتكون كتله موازيه لمجموعات دوليه اخرى
مثل مجموعه السبع ولتشكيل ثقل مقابل
للهيمنه الجيوسيه الغربيه الجدل الذي
ذكرناه يعود لشهر مارس الماضي عندما اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره توقيف بحق
بوتين بتهمه ارتكاب جريمه حرب على خلفيه
نقل الاطفال اوكرانيين الى روسيا نقشنا
هذا الموضوع انذاك هنا باستفاضه المذكره
او المذكره هذه اوقعت جنوب افريقيا تحديدا
في معضله خاصه وانها من الدول الموقعه على
قانون روما الاساسي الذي انشا المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولذلك يجب نظريا على
الاقل القاء القبض على بوتين اذا وصل الى
جنوب افريقيا لكن الاخيره واجهت الموقف من
قبل عندما سمحت للرئيس السوداني السابق
عمر البشير بالدخول الى البلاد للمشاركه
في قمه الاتحاد الافريقي عام 2015 بينما
كان متهما انذاك بارتكاب اباده جماعيه
وجرائم حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه لذلك
اصدرت جنوب افريقيا حصانه دبلوماسيه شامله
لجميع القاده الذين يتوقع ان يشاركوا في
قمه بريكس في اغسطس واعتبرت وزاره
الخارجيه ان منح الحصانات هدفه حمايه
المؤتمر وضيوفه في المقابل اعلن حزب
التحالف الديمقراطي المعارض في جنوب
افريقيا يوم الثلاثاء عن اتخاذ اجراءات
قانونيه لاجبار الحكومه على اعتقال بوتين
في حال قرر حضور قمه دول بريكس وضمان قيام
الحكومه بتسليمه الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
بشكل عام تجده جنوب افريقيا نفسها في مازق
بين مواجهه روسيا حليفتها التاريخيه او
الحفاظ على العلاقات مع الغرب وعدم تنفيره
وايجاد توازن بهذا الشان اما في روسيا فقد
دعا المتحدث باسم الكرملين الى ان لا تركز
الدول الشريكه في بريكس على ما اسماها
القرارات غير القانونيه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ضد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
دعونا نتابع هذا الموضوع بالمزيد من
التفصيل مع الدكتور مجيد بودان استاذ
القانون الدولي من باريس وقبل ان اتوجه
اليك نذهب الى هذه الصور المباشره اذا
تعرض الرئيس الامريكي سقوط واضح بشده اذا
تعرض الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لحادث سقوط
خلال مشاركته في تخريج طلاب من القوات
الجويه هذه الصوره التي لدينا حتى الان
توضح سقوطه بشكل كامل على الارض ولكن يبدو
انه يحاول النهوض بمساعده عدد من
المسؤولين الامنيين بجانبه وقد استطاع
النهوض
ومضي قدما بعد ذلك طبعا يؤخذ على الرئيس
الامريكي من قبل معارضيها يعني تعرضوا
لمثل هذه المواقف اكثر من مره كما حصل على
سلم الطائره في احدى المرات بينما كان
يهبط من على سلمها والان تتكرر هذه اللقطه
اضافه الى مرات وعثارات اخرى اخذت عليها
ليست فقط جسديا انما ايضا كزلات لسان من
خلال تجاوز عدد من المراسم التي كانت
مفترضه من خلال نسيان بعض الاسماء او وضع
اسم مكان اخر وهذا ياتي طبعا عشيره
الانتخابات المرتقبه عشيه رمزيا يعني بما
انه الحم
[تصفيق]
سلامته
الجسمانيه ام لا سنعود الى هذا الموضوع
فور ورود اي تفاصيل اضافيه هذه كل الصور
التي لدينا حتى الان
من باريس دكتور مجيد بودان استاذ القانون
الدولي اهلا بك معنا دكتور هذه عوده اذا
الى موضوع جنوب افريقيا وبوتين
قانونيا او في القانون الدولي هل يمكن ان
نقول انه مقامت به جنوب افريقيا من خلال
يعني ان قامت بذلك واتمته من خلال منح
الحصانه الدبلوماسيه يعتبر ذلك غير قانوني
ويمكن ان تحاسب عليه هو كيف
المساله واضحه الدوله التي
تمضي وتوافق وتصادق على معاهده يجب ان
تحترمه تلك المعاهده وهذه المعاهده تقول
انه يجب ايقاف من
تريد ان توقفه محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وبالتالي فان جنوب افريقيا ملتزمه بذلك
وعليها ان تنفذ ذلك وان لم تقم بذلك فهي
مسؤوله اما يعني على اساس القانون الدولي
امام المجتمع الدولي
لانها لم تطبق اتفاقيه التزمت فيها
الخطوات التي هذا هو المبدا نعم الخطوات
التي قامت بها الجمهوريه جنوب افريقيا
الان وهي
اصدار
امل
رئاسي او امر من من الدوله بشكل عام من
وزاره الخارجيه بان تعطي
الدبلوماسيه او ما تفكر فيه الحكومه الان
وهي ان تطلب من البرلمان بالقيام
بالتصويت على قانون يعطيها يعطي للحكومه
ولرئيس الجمهوريه امكانيه اعطاء
الحسن الدبلوماسيه بشكل
تختاره هي كل هذه القرارات هي لا يمكن ان
تعلو وان تسمو الى مستوى القانون الدولي
وبالتالي فهي غير لا يمكنها ان تفسخ ما
تحميها امام المجتمع الدولي ولكن
ان حصل
العديد من المرات السابقه حصل فيها تجاوز
في هذا الاطار تحديدا اقصد للقانون الدولي
مثل حاله عمر البشير التي ذكرناها 2015
يعني عندما قام ايضا بزيارات مماثله
هذه يجب على دوله اخرى ان تقوم
بطلب محاسبه جنوب افريقيا وان وجدت هذه
الدوله فيمكن ان تحمل
جنوب افريقيا هذه المسؤوليه ولكن المهم ان
كل القوانين وكل الترتيبات وكل القرارات
التي يمكن ان تاخذها مهما كان ولو تصويت
من البرلمان لا يعطيها من
مسؤوليتها الدوليه لان الاتفاقيات الدوليه
هي اسمى من الدستور نفسه ومن القوانين ومن
القرارات وبالتالي هذه المساله هي محسومه
من ناحيه القانون الدولي وهناك مسؤوليه هل
الان هناك من سيقوم بهذا الاجراء ام لا
هذا هو قرار سياسي قرار الدبلوماسي نفصل
قليلا لو سمحت فيما لو قام الدوله
بتقديم شكوى ضد جنوب افريقيا يعني
ماذا يكون حاصلا عندها
اذا رفعت قضيه ضد جنوب افريقيا من دوله
ترى ان لها مصلحه في ذلك يجب على الدوله
ان تكون لها مصلحه ولو كانت المصلحه
اعتباريه ورمزيه اي مصلحه الدوله يمكن ان
تكون في انه ممكن يتقدم طلب مثلا او شكوى
ممكن اوكرانيا ستكون سعيده بذلك اي بلد
اخر
واي دوله اخرى يمكن ان تقوم بذلك
والضرر الذي يحصل لتلك الدوله هي انه وقع
الاخلال بالقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي
الحفاظ على القانون الدولي هو مصلحه لكل
دوله ترى في القانون الدولي الاساسي في
التعامل الدولي وبالتالي المساحه موجوده
صفه القيام موجوده
اذا المثل الان تبقى في يد اي دوله ستقوم
بذلك وان قامت بذلك
يمكن حسب القانون الدولي ان يقع الاعلان
ان جنوب افريقيا لم تطبق هذه الاتفاقيه
وخرقت القانون الدولي ويمكن ان
يقع الطلب منها
بتعويضات
يجب ان نتوقف هنا ولكن نشير الى انه طبعا
كل تصريحات الطرف المحور الاخر في بريكس
يتحدث عن عدم عداله هذا القانون الدولي
الذي نتحدث عن وعن ازدواجته وعن تلبيته
مصالح الدول الغربيه
الكبرى لكن هدف كان هو الان هو عادل هو
القانون هو عادل لانه وقع الاقرار به من
من
المجتمع الدولي ولكن يمكن كذلك للمحاكم
جنوب افريقيا اذا وقع كما كما قامت
المعارضه بذلك يمكن ان تقول للحكومه وتامر
الحكومه بان تطبق ذلك القانون وتعيد خلق
الاوراق وهذا هو الموضوع يعني الان مطروح
على يبقى اذا مفتوحا على كل الاحتمالات
ونتابعه اولا باول معكم دائما دكتور مجيد
بودان استاذ القانون الدولي من باريس شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه التوضيحات تحياتي اليك
نعود الى الهجمات الاخيره التي تعرضت لها
روسيا مؤخرا حيث ان هذه الهجمات المتكرره
تتعامل معها موسكو بقليل من الاهميه رغم
خطورتها اعلام غربي يركز على ان هيبه ثاني
اكبر دوله عسكريه تضررت بعد تعرض موسكو
لهجمات هي الاولى منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
في بدايه مايو من هذا العام هاجم الطائرات
مسيره مبنى الكرملين وسط موسكو استنفرت
القوات الروسيه وسرع الرئيس الاوكراني
او موسكو نحن نحارب في ارضنا وندافع عن
وطننا
هذه المره لا شيء يمكن اخفاؤه او نثيره
موسكو تحت القصف
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه قالت انها تحتفظ
بحق الرد بينما خرج الرئيس الروسي هادئا
يتحدث عن تعزيز دفاعات حول العاصمه
انظمه موسكو المضاده للصواريخ عملت كما
ينبغي رغم ان هناك اشياء يجب تحسينها لقد
واجهنا بالفعل نفس المشكله في قاعده حميم
الجويه في سوريا على الرغم من انه لا
يمكنك مقارنه قاعدتنا الجويه في حميم
بموسكو هذه مدينه اوروبيه ضخمه لكن بشكل
عام نحن نفهم ما يتعين علينا القيام به
لتعزيز نظام عاصمتنا المضاد للصواريخ
وسنفعل ذلك
دول اوروبيه انتشر الدفع لثاني اقوى قوه
عسكريه في العالم مؤكده ان ما تقدمه من
اسلحه ليكياف مخصص لدفاع وليس لنقل
المعركه داخل روسيا
اخر مره تعرضت فيها موسكو لقصف حقيقي كان
في اربعينيات القرن الماضي خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بينما تعرضت نيويورك
لقصف بالطائرات في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
عام 2001 ردت عليها الولايات المتحده
بحروب قتل فيها اكثر من خمسه ملايين انسان
[موسيقى]
وتتابعنا معنا في العربيه
300 على عناصر بالحرس الثوري الايراني
والسبب التخطيط لاستهداف مسؤولين امريكيين
سابقين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تمكنت كاميرا العربيه من
الدخول الى مطار الخرطوم الدولي ووثقت حجم
الدمار الذي لحق بالمرافق الخدميه
والاحتراق الكامل لصاله المغادره الاساسيه
للمسافرين
اهلا بكم نحن الان داخل مطار الخرطوم
الدولي الذي دارت فيه الاشتباكات منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم دارت هذه
الاشتباكات وخلفت كثير من الدمار والخراب
ندخل الان الى صاله المغادره وهذه هي
الصاله الاساسيه التي كان يعبر من خلالها
الكثيرين الى وجهات العالم المختلفه نحن
الان داخل الصاله الرئيسيه للمغادره حيث
كان يقف هنا عدد من المسافرين
ويتجمعون لعمليات السفر واجراء عدد من
الاجراءات الرسميه للسفر في هذه في هذا
المكان كان يقف المسافرون
وتتم من خلالها الاجراءات الرسميه المتبعه
في صلاه السفر العالميه تشاهد هذا الدمار
وهذا الخراب الذي لحق بهذا المكان عدد
كبير من السيارات التي كانت تتوقف في مطار
الخرطوم تعرضت للحرق بشكل واضح جرار
الاشتباكات التي دارت موندو الخامس عشر
جبريل نشاهد ذلك من خلال هذه المشاهد وهذه
الصور الحصريه لقناتها العربيه والحدث من
امام صاله الحج والعمره ومن الناحيه
الشرقيه ننظر الى
مهبط الطائرات الرئيسي في مطار العاصمه
الخرطوم بحسب ما نشاهد لم يتضرر جراء
الاشتباكات العسكريه ولكن عدد من الطائرات
شاهدناها محروقه او محترقه بالشكل الكامل
هنا هي صاله الحج والعمره حيث يتجهز كثير
جدا من المعتمرين والحاجين الى بيت الله
الحرام في كل عام ويخرجون من هذه الصاله
الى هذه السيارات التي تقف وتنقل كثير جدا
من المسافرين الى الطائرات التي كانت
تتوقف في القرب من هذا المكان حتى عدد من
الشركات العامله في مطار الخرطوم نلاحظ ان
عدد من السيارات
محطمه بشكل جزئي وتوقفت بشكل كامل
الجوازات سفر وهواتف نق اله محطمه ولكن
هنا الصاله الحج والعمره ما زالت بخير لم
تتحطم الجراء الاجتباكات العسكريه التي
دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع في الخامس
عشر من ابريل المنصرم بعد 47 يوما من
القتال كنا معكم هنا داخل مطار الخرطوم
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار ابو شيبه
شكرا جزيلا لك يعني صور حصريه ولو مؤلمه
من حيث حجم الدمار الهائل الذي تعرض له
مطار الخرطوم الدولي نرى هذه الصور بهذه
الدقه والتفصيل للمره الاولى بعد كل ما
سمعناها عن تعرض المطار لهذه
يعني بعد التعرضه لكل هذه العمليات
العسكريه هذه الصور الحصريه لقناه العربيه
التي
تكون بذلك المحطه الاولى عالميا التي تدخل
المطار لتصور هذه الصور الحصريه التي
عرضناها للتو ونعيدها ان شاء الله لاحقا
عليكم في سياق نشراتنا لما تعرض له مطار
الخرطوم الدولي بعد العمليات العسكريه بين
طرفي النزاع في السودان
اعربت السعوديه وامريكا عن قلقهما من
الانتهاكات الجسيمه لوقف النار في السودان
كما اعلن بيان سعودي امريكي عن تعليق
مفاوضات الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع لعدم جديه الطرفين وفقا لما اشار
له البيان واكدت السعوديه وامريكا انه
وبمجرد ان تتضح جديه طرفي الصراع فسيكون
هناك استعداد لمناقشه حل تفاوضي واشار
البيان الى ان الانتهاكات بالسودان اضرت
بالمدنيين وايصال المساعدات لهم وحثت
السعوديه وامريكا طرفي الصراع على
الالتزام بجديه وقف النار
قبل ذلك فرضت واشنطن عقوبات اقتصاديه على
طرفي الصراع في السودان كما منعت
التاشيرات عنهم من جهته قال مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي ان فشل وقف اطلاق النار
بالسودان سيزيد من مخاوف واشنطن من صراع
طويل الامد ومعاناه واسعه النطاق كما اكد
ان بلاده ستواصل فعل كل ما في وسعها لمنع
طول امد الصراع ومعاناه المدنيين
معنى من مسقط دكتور جمال الامين ادم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك معنا من
القاهره اللواء معتصم العجب المحلي
العسكري السوداني اهلا بك معنا كذلك ابدا
معك من القاهره لواء معتصم اذا يبدو انه
يعني
ضاقت ذرعا بالطرفين
وحملتهما المسؤوليه مشتركين يعني هل ما
تعليقك على ذلك اولا
بعد الهدى السلام عليكم اولا وعليكم
السلام مرحبا بالساده المشاهدين وضيفنا
الكريم
اكيد يعني الطرفين اللي هم الواسطه
اجتهدوا كثيرا
لما الشمل
ووطف القتال حتى الفترات السابقه
ما في جديه يعني يمكن
اخر
كانت الودن القبلي دي اللي هي عشره ايام
في اول بدا قتال في اخره كم قتال لكن في
فتره الامور كانت هذه فلازم التزام
الطرفين
وانا افتكر يعني انت توافق على تحميل
المسؤوليه مشتركه الى الطرفين
ما فيش حد يقدر ياكد لك من على الارض يعني
ما فيش ما عندك مراقبين عشان ياكدوا لك
طرفي عشان تدين كويس ومن البدء بس
العقوبات ستؤثر من اتحرك
[موسيقى]
نعم التحيه لك ولضيوفك الكرام اهلا بك
بالنسبه لهذه العقوبات هي عقوبات سياسيه
لا تؤثر كثيرا في هذا الامر ولكن ما كنا
نتمنى ان توصل الى هذه المواصيل بالنسبه
لشركه شركات الجنرال الحميدي هذه شركات
خاصه ولها مساهمين
ليست لها علاقه مباشره
بخزينه خزينه الدوله السودانيه ولكن
العقوبات التي تقع على جانب الجيش وكل
الشعب السوداني يتاثر بها اكيد
ولذلك يجب التوقف الحرب هذا الذي نطالب به
توقف الحرب لان الشعب قد عانى معاناه قويه
جدا جدا ونحن هذه الشركات التي تتحدث عنها
هي شركات تسهم
بغض النظر عن السبب او او من له الحق او
ليس له الحق في ذلك في قتل السودانيين وفي
هذه الحرب المستعره في السودان خاصه عامه
فيها مساهمين ما فيهاش مساهمين شركات
محدوده مش محدوده هذه مساهمه في القتل
لا لا اعتقد ان شركات
الجنرال الحميتين مساهمه في القتل بقدر ما
انها مساهمه في يعني تشال الفقر من كثير
من المواطنين السودان صراحه
قوات الدعم السريع قدمت الكثير جدا جدا
وما زالت تقدم حتى في هذه الازمه ولكن
خلينا ناخذ هل توافق على هذا الكلام
العقوبات العقوبات فعلا هي تاثير حيكون
مباشر على الشعب السوداني
لانه الشركات
جمدت بالذات الصناعات الدفاعيه في الاخر
حكينا عن العقوبات ضيفنا الكريم من مسقط
يقول
هي شركات خاصه ولها مساهمون وهي افادت
الشعب السوداني
بشرائحه المختلفه وبالتالي يعني من غير
العادل ان تخضع لمثل هذه العقوبات وانا
قلت له بانه هي مشاركه في الحرب الدائره
الان كما هو الجيش مشارك على قدم المساواه
ما رايك انسيه لواء
لا اكيد اكيد ده التابعه للجنرال اكيد
بتساهم مساهمات حتى مباشره او غير مباشره
في دعم
القوات بتاعته يعني او اي نقص هي جاهزه
يعني حتى احتياطي بالنسبه له يعني دي ما
فيها ما فيها شك يعني
حقيقه يعني
ما تم في في الايام اللي فاتت دي المفروض
قوات الدعم السريع
تلتفت له وما تم من الجنود في الارض انا
عارف انه في حملات مضاده
لتشويه صوره الدعم السريع لكن لازم تكون
فيه جديه من القيادات بتاعه الدعم السريع
على الارض ان يعني في في بتجي بعض البلد
بتجي في حاجات كويسه عنه وبتجي في نفس
الوقت حاجات سيئه فتفلت
الجنود على الارض لازم تكون فيه وقفه لانه
الدعم السريع حماتي
الجنود اقصد جنود الدعم السريعي نعم
دعنا ناخذ رد رد الاستاذ الامين هو انا
معك بس خليني اكمل اتفضل اتفضل مستهدفين
باشياء مفبركه مستهدفين بانه في ناس بتلبس
لبس الدعم السريع اللي هو موجود كان في
مصنع كبير
يعني في ناس بتكون عندهم لبس الشرطه
والدعم السريع والجيش والقوات الخاصه وكل
الاشياء هذه فانا معاك لكن حصلت بعد
الاحداث
الناس بيشيدوا بها وفي بعض الاحداث السيئه
طبعا الناس دائما بتتذكر السيء فلازم
توجيهي يعني لقياده الدعم السريع انها
يعني توجه افراد الموجودين او القيادات
الموجوده في الميدان بانها تحسم معامله
المواطنين لانه نزل
فيش في كل الشوارع في منتشرين في 80% من
الخرطوم اذا هم اتهمون
بسوء معامله الناس في الناس وهذا ما ننقله
الى ضيفنا من مصنع افضل كيف ترد على هذه
النقاط
[موسيقى]
فهذه هي كلها مشكله كبيره
ولكن الطرف الاخر ايضا هو الذي يحمل قوات
الدعم السريع هذه الممارسات على الارض وما
حصل في السجون
وممارسات بعض الجنود التابعين لقوات الدعم
السريع مع الناس
عمليات النهب احتلال منازل المواطنين حتى
في بيان
الوساطه المشتركه في في بيان تحميل
المسؤوليات يوم الاحد ذكر هذا الموضوع
تحديدا الغارات الجويه من الجيش واحتلال
منازل من قبل دعم السريع اذا هناك تحميل
متساوي للمسؤوليات بين الطرفين وارى
محاوله من ضيفينا الكريمين يعني لتجميل
المسؤوليات مسؤوليات الدعم السريع اكثر من
تحميل المسؤوليات للدعم السريع بشكل
متساوي كما تقول الولايات المتحده وكما
تقول السعوديه في البيان المشترك
ارى ان
بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع كثيرا ما
تجدها ملتزمه واكثر حرصا لحمايه المواطنين
فلذلك عندما يظهر فيديو في وانتهاء
لجهه ما سواء كان مركز مثل مركز الاطفال
في الماريجوما او مستشفى او اي استنجاد من
مواطنين
فبسرعه البرق يكون شاوس الدعم السريع امام
المشكله ويحاصروها ومن هناك يرسلوا
فيديوهات بانهم كانوا هنا فكما
ظهر في فيديو
لبدايه الحرب للسفيه السفير الاوروبي
فقد تهجموا عليه بعض
المتفلتين
وفعلا وصلت قوات الدعم السريع
وامانته تماما وقد شكر على ذلك في فيديو
منتشرا الان ولكن لا ينطبق ذلك ايضا على
الجيش سياده اللواء واختم معك تفضل
سياده لواء معتصم بالعجب الا ينطبق نفس
الكلام على هبه ونجده كما يقول ضيفنا
الكريم القوات الدعم السريع على الجيش وما
فعله في كل هذه الفتره مع السودانيين
احنا نكون واضحين واضحين يعني
لا في صحافه مستغله يعني الاخبار كلها
بتجي عبر وسائل التواصل
فما في اخبار او جهات مؤكده تديك اخبار
موثقه واخبار مؤكده
او ماذا وراء الاكل يعني لكن الحاصل انه
الضغط على الدعم السريع من الناحيه دي
الضغط على الدعم السريع فلازم الناس ينتهي
اول حاجه في اشياء مفروض تحصل اللي هو
الخروج من منازل الناس يعني لو في قوات
موجوده في منازل الناس ما في ضروره انه
القوات تكون موجوده فيها كما قال بيان
الاحد الاستيلاء على الممتلكات واحتلال
منازل المواطنين
الدعم السريع الجيش
لانه المرحله الجايه لازم يكون شو راغبين
في الارض يعني كل الكلام ده ان اثبت
الطرفان استعدادهما لابداء الجديه اللازمه
كما قال
استعدادهم ان ابديا ذلك انا ساكتفي معكما
بهذا القدر اعذرني سياده اللواء شكرا
جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من مسقط دكتور
جمال الامين ادم تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
مشهد التوتر المحتدم بين كوسوفو وصربيا
يتصاعد يوما بعد يوم لتصبح زاويه تبادل
الاتهامات بين رئيسي البلدين سيده الموقف
وتغطي على معارك الميدان التي لم تسفر عن
اصابات اليوم
فعلى ما يبدو صربيا لا تزال تنكر سياده
كوسوفو بحسب تصريحات رئيستها فويس عثماني
التي اتهمت نظيرها الصربي بتقديم الدعم
لجماعات مسلحه واشعال فتيل الفتنه شمالي
البلاد
ودعم رئيس صربيا الكساندر فوتشيتش سياسيا
وماليا هياكل غير قانونيه تحولت الى
عصابات اجراميه هي جماعات الجريمه المنظمه
العابره للحدود وهي مجموعات خطيره للغايه
تسببت ايضا في العنف ضد جنود النيتو
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر فاما كره الجليد في
ملعب نظيرته لاخماد الاشتباك الدائر عبر
التراجع عن القرار المتعلق برؤساء
البلديات الالبان ليرد على اتهاماتها
باستعداده اقناع شعبه بالاحتجاج بهدوء في
وقت دفع بتعزيزات عسكريه لجيشه على الحدود
انهم مصممون وحاسمون للغايه اعتقد ان
الخطوه التي قد تحل المشاكل هي انسحاب
رؤساء البلديات المزعومين
تخوفات اوروبيه من مشهد التصعيد بين
البلدين وصدعوات الى نزعفه للتوتر على
الفور ودون قيد او شرط فالخلاف القائم
قديم جديد عمره عقدان من الزمن لكنه قد
ينذر بتفجير محتمل في اوروبا
فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على اعضاء
بالحرس الثوري الايراني وشركه تابعه لفيلق
القدس وذلك نظراتها من تتعلق بالمشاركه في
تدبير مؤامرات ارهابيه تستهدف مسؤولين
سابقين في الحكومه الامريكيه ومواطنين
يحملون الجنسيتين الامريكيه والايرانيه
ومنشقين ايرانيين
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
زفاف اسطوري لولي العهد الاردني الامير
الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني على الاميره
رجوى ال سيف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى هذه الصور
والمشاهد من الاحتفالات بزفاف ولي العهد
الاردني الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
على الاميره رجوى الصيف تجد تعرضنا هذه
الصور وهذا وزير الخارجيه ايمن الصفدي
الان يقوم بالسلامه على العائله المالكه
وكذلك لدينا يعني هذه المره ليست الاولى
طبعا التي يعقد فيها
قران امير اردني وشخصيات اردنيه على انسات
سعوديات او العكس فالعلاقات الاجتماعيه و
روابط النسب والمظاهره تجمع بين العائلات
السعوديه والاردنيه كان مثل ما حصل مع
الامير هاشم بن الحسين
فهد ابو ريان او عندما ارتبطت الاميره
نوره بنت عاصم حفيده الملك عبد الله الاول
ملك المملكه الاردنيه الاسبق من رجل
الاعمال والفارس السعودي عمرو زيدان والان
عقد قران جديد امتداد عشائري وروابط اسريه
كبيره تجمع
ومشاركه في العادات والتقاليد وتراث
والثقافه والاهازيج الشعبيه وحتى الاطباق
الغذائيه هناك نصف مليون اردني مع
عائلاتهم في السعوديه وعدد السعوديين
السياح الى الاردن يصل الى مليون ونصف
سائح سعودي في 2019 كما هي الاحصاءات
انذاك سنتابع اي صور ومشاهد جديده تريدنا
من حفل الزفاف في هذه النشره او في نشرات
لاحقا نتابع الان من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري الامريكي لن تنطلق قبل فبراير
المقبل لكن الساحه بدات تزدحم بالمترشحين
المحتملين لنقل النتيجه حتى الان خمسه
مترشحين عن الحزب الجمهوري ومرشح وحيد عن
الحزب الديمقراطي هو الرئيس جو بايدن فمن
هم هؤلاء الخمسه اولهم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ما راح نشوف صورته طيب
الاوفر حظا الذي اع ترشحه في الخامس عشر
من نوفمبر الماضي ويعتبر الاوفر حظا اذا
الا ان احدى العقبات التي قد تواجهه هي
عدم اليقين القانوني مع تعرضه لمحاكمه في
نيويورك ولتحقيقات مستمره بولايه جورجيا
اما المرشح الثاني فهو حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
الحالي راندي سانتس وهو ذو الشعبيه
الكبيره في اوساط الحزب الجمهوري خاصه لدى
الاطراف التي تحاول النائيه بنفسها عن
الرئيس السابق اضافه للقبول الذي يتمتع به
مع اقراره لعده مشاريع قوانين نالت رضا
القاعده الجمهوريه في فلوريدا بعد ذلك
لدينا مرشحان من ساف كارولاينا اولهما
نكهه الحاكمه السابقه للولايه والممثله
السابقه للولايات المتحده بالامم المتحده
تذكرون هذا الوجه جيدا اثناء فتره حكم
ترامب ثانيهما عضو مجلس الشيوخ تمسكت وهو
العضو الجمهوري الوحيد من مجلس من اصول
افريقيه
وعينتهيلي بصفتها حاكمه للولايه محل سينات
اخر من الولايه اعلن عن تقاعده في عام
2012 لدينا ايضا مرشحون نقلت عنهم وسائل
الاعلام امريكيه نيتهم الترشح منهم نائب
الرئيس السابق
الذي من المتوقع ان يعلن عن ترشحه للرئاسه
قريبا وربما يتمكن من سحب جانب من مؤيدي
المرشحين الاخرين لدعمه ننتقل لاستطلاع
راي اجرته السي ان ان يوم الاربعاء من
الاسبوع الماضي اظهر ان ترامب في المرتبه
الاولى بثلاثه وخمسين في المئه بين محل
ديسانتس ثانيا فقط حصل كل من على السته
بالمئه من تفضيلات الناخبين الجمهوريين
وفقا لاستطلاع الراي ما يعني ان السباق
ربما سينحصر بين ترامب وديسم فقط معنى من
واشنطن عبر سكايب بشار جرار الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك معنا استاذ بشار
مره جديده على شاشه العربيه هل توافق ام
ان الايام
والفتره المتبقيه يمكن ان تكون حبله
بالمفاجات
شكرا على الدعوه الكريمه واقول ان واضح
هناك اعاده اعاده لما جرى بعشرين عشرين
على الارجح الرئيس ترامب الرئيس السابق
سيفوز بالتصفيات الداخليه في صفوف الحزب
جمهوري لانه في حقيقه الامر لا يوجد الا
منافس واحد حقيقي هو كما المحتم هناك تقدم
فارق يصل الى الضعف بين ترامب وديسانس ومن
يؤيد الرئيس ترامب ومن يعارضه هناك حاله
من الاستقطاب في داخل حزب الجمهوري تقول
باننا نريد تكرار تجربه ترامب لانه هو وعد
بانه الكامباك بمعنى عودت امريكا او عظيمه
ستتحقق على يديه ووفقا للاجنده التي
تبناها وليس بالضروره ان تكون الحاله من
السجال مستمره امام ضعف الرئيس ما ابرز
نقطه قوه عندها
ديسانس يمكن ان يعمل عليها ضد ترامب
المراهنه دائما هي على ان الرئيس ترامب
فيما لو عاد الكره ونافس رئيس بايدن هناك
ما سينتخب بايدن لا لشيء الا نكايه او
كراهيه لما يمثل الرئيس ترامب سواء اجنده
او سلوك الذي يعد به ديسانس ويحاول الكثير
من الجمهوريين الوقوف خلف ديسانس بانه لا
بد من نفس جديد لابد من صوره جديده خاصه
ايضا كبير في السن كما بايدن بالرغم من
الفارق بالنشاط بين الطرفين ولكن نحن
بحاجه الى ثمان سنوات وليس فقط اربع سنوات
لا يستطيع الا ان يظهر بولايه اضافيه فيما
نفاذ بينما دي سانتوس قد يحقق ما يراد الى
امريكا بان تتراجع عن كل ما قام به اوباما
خلال الولايات البعض يقول انها ثلاث
ولايات عمليا الشيخ بذلك طبعا الى ولايه
الرئيس
الحاليه استاذ بشار جرار انا ساكتفي معك
بهذا القدر ولو كان قليلا ولكن لنا لقاءات
كثيره اخرى ان شاء الله في الحمله طيله
الحمله الانتخابيه لطرفين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي بشار جرار شكرا جزيلا لك تحياتي
اليك ونختم العربيه 360 وانا التوجه فورا
الى ميسون
مساء الخير طاهر الموضوع الاول هو ادانه
السعوديه وامريكا لانتهاكات الهدنه في
الخرطومه الموضوع الثاني ايضا العربيه
تدخل مطار الخرطوم وتوثق الدمار الحاصل
هناك ايضا هناك سقوط او حادث سقوط الرئيس
بايدن بالاضافه الى التطورات الحاصله في
بالقرود والعديد من الاخبار وطبعا ايضا
العرس الملكي زفاف الملكي اليوم في الاردن
نتمنى ان تتابعنا ان شاء الله ساكون معك
اللي قلت لك اياه تحت الهواء
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات